hi I'm Erik Bosse and with Avengers
infinity war approaching a question has
been brought up that is facing Thanos
and pretty much every Marvel movie
villain to this point who is this guy
and how do we kill him now sure that
sounds a bit too bloodthirsty the MCU
needs more good villains we shouldn't be
too focused on how to get rid of them so
soon but us I mean we'll get plenty of
time with feyo's and both infinity War
part 1 & 2 let's dig into the nature of
this villain what makes him unique from
his story in the Marvel comics and what
interesting sacrifices might have to be
made to ultimately bring him down and no
I'm not just referring to ant-man
shrinking down flying into Thanos's ear
canal and then re expanding the blow up
as head though that would be so let's
break down five possible weaknesses of
fan o's based on what past films have
suggested and what we know about it from
the comics and spoiler warning in case
you don't want to know any of those
comic events and prefer to go into the
movie blind okay first let's quickly
remind ourselves of what Thanos even is
As Seen the Marvel Comics he was born on
Saturn's moon Titan
a child of Eternals but born with a
genetic defect that gave him his scarred
purple appearance his mother's seeing
the evil in his eyes tried to kill him
but failed and yeah by the way those
lines on Thanos his face are indeed
birthmarks he's always had them they are
not fresh scars given him by Black
Panther Captain America as new shield or
green or anything crazy as Thanos grew
older he became obsessed with nihilism
and death eventually falling in love and
worshiping an embodiment of death known
as mistress death hoping to impress her
he goes on a universe wide killing spree
killing millions of his own race and
thousands of planets and star systems he
wipes out half the universe in his
pursuit of the infinity gems and
Infinity Gauntlet which has of course
inspired the events that were now seen
in the movies nemesis acquisition of the
Infinity stones would essentially make
him immortal invincible to any physical
attack by the Avengers or any cosmic
forces even if they could overpower the
Power Stone for example using star Lords
celestial power
vanna's could just use the time stone to
rewind the clock on their attacks the
way Doctor Strange did did your mama or
use the reality stone to bounce them
between realities ruled by giant butts
and ones where phones sit on pizzas
dialling people to order soap us to eat
Dan Harmon worked on Doctor Strange guys
so the MCU brick and Laurie crossover
has already begun to defeat a god you
have to either appeal to some even
higher power and sure in the Marvel
Comics supreme cosmic forces like
eternity and the Living Tribunal do
exist but for them to drop in as some
kind of deus ex machina would feel like
a cheat or use that god's personality
against him like his pride or his
emotional vulnerability so this brings
us to Thanos his first possible weakness
death you know I guess in the end death
is all of our weakness now for real
mistress death thanassis pursuit of her
love could lead to some kind of union
with this cosmic figure that would
involve him departing this realm you
know kind of like detaching his
consciousness from his physical body to
join death and some other dimension yeah
I know it seems like one of those wait
huh things that only really make sense
in comics but the movies did tease
Thanos his secret crush in his first
appearance in the post-credits scene
after Avengers 2 challenge is too good
[Music]
now of course we could read that
courting death joke as just a easter egg
pun winking at Vanessa's core motivator
in the comics rather than a serious
indicator of death being an actual
character in the movies as she is in the
comics in a way there are some other
weaknesses that do lead to this death
union happening with Manas that we
should discuss bringing us to our second
vulnerability of Thanos nebula in Adam
warlock so these two characters are
really the ones that lead the fantasies
defeat in the Infinity Gauntlet Comics
nebula of course the Stannis's always
spiteful daughter meanwhile Adam warlock
is a genetically perfect human who has
the soul gem in his forehead he has
deity like powers now at first it seemed
like the Marvel movies were
reappropriation that I deal with vision
giving him the mind stone in his
forehead then and one of the
post-credits scenes after guardians the
galaxy vol 2 Aisha teased Adam warlocks
upcoming entrance to the MCU so in this
comic storyline Bannos acquires the
Infinity Gauntlet and more and less
vanquishes all of his enemies
The Avengers also the more cosmic powers
of the Marvel world so out of pride his
consciousness departs his physical body
to go to an astral plane that's when
nebula steals the gauntlet from his
physical body attacks him and then
through a convoluted series of events
involving a heart-to-heart with Adam
warlock nebula undoes Thanos his
destruction and hands off the gauntlet
to warlock who decides to separate each
infinity gem to people he deems worthy
meanwhile Thanos retires to work on a
farm because comics guys yeah this all
seems a little wacky for the movie
version of this story but I guess it
would be interesting to see the heroes
if not Adam warlock since we haven't
really met him yet maybe Tony Stark or
cap or Thor doctor trained or vision
instead of destroying Thanos negotiating
a similar truce with him that involves a
mutual sacrifice in all their parts
maybe one of them saying hey if you lay
off vanos I'll give up my life you know
so a new generation of Avengers can take
over the franchise also it would be
satisfying to see nebula play a big part
in famous is undoing The Forgotten
daughter coming back to bite the old man
in the ass having set aside her
vengeance to instead reverse the pain
her father inflicted on the universe but
there's another supporting MCU character
aiming for
against Thanos who could end up being
another blind spot corner cracks a
destroyer and the first guardians of the
galaxy Drax initially swore vengeance on
Ronan the accuser for the death of his
wife and daughter before declaring
Thanos as his next target actually in
the annihilation storyline in the comics
Drax actually succeeds in killing Thanos
dana says distracted trying to prevent a
larger calamity from happening and Drax
fulfills his life mission by punching
through Thanos his back and ripping his
heart out but really Thanos his death is
just a little anticlimactic here right
since in this story it meant an even
larger threat to the universe would be
coming now still you can bet that Drax
in the movies will still be on this
mission without spoiling anything leaked
footage has shown Drax repeating his
personal desire to kill the man Titan
even if it's not the best time to launch
that attack really the MCU plans to pay
off Drax and nebulas subplots from the
Guardians movies these two characters
will need to play some role in
destabilizing Thanos but let's move on
to another threat to Thanos who remember
is a god so powerful that no physical
threat can hurt him except maybe a force
with unlimited durability himself walk
while Hulk probably isn't strong enough
to overpower Thanos his strength only
increases with his rage suggesting he
could continue to fight blow-for-blow
against Thanos without exhaustion I'd
say both Hulk and Thanos are the kind of
powers that don't really get defeated so
much as contained so I could see a
scenario where these to fight for eons
down to a standstill we actually saw a
similar version of this kind of strategy
before in the MCU which leads me to the
final weakness on our list
I'm the destroyer of a saw specifically
time as we saw it used by Doctor Strange
one of the most intriguing elements of
the Doctor Strange movies ending was
that strange didn't fully defeat
Dormammu instead he manipulated the eye
of agamotto slash time stone to trap
Dormammu in a time loop and gradually
drive him insane
I think this tactic gave us a sense of
other more out-of-the-box ways these
cosmic forces can be brought down in the
MCU whatever attack planned the Avengers
use on vanos will probably need as part
of the recipe trapping or confusing
Thanos by manipulating realities or time
loops in a similar fashion I mean
ultimately we're probably looking at a
combination of these tactics right like
Doctor Strange forcing Thanos to fight
in a disadvantageous reality or time
loop meanwhile star-lord Thor and Hulk
leading the charge to fight him
physically
nebulae and racks hitting him in the
heart to fulfill their vengeance
ambitions all while Iron Man cap and
vision would appeal to his reason in
some possible truce negotiation maybe
this will even lead to some kind of
timeline reset where the heroes will
have to refight there are old infinity
stone related battles which could be why
those set photos for infinity War part 2
showed several of them with clocks on
their hands and Captain America wearing
his older Avengers era suit now my
imaginations running a little while too
here so all throw it over to you guys
what Banias weakness do you see is the
most interesting possible source of his
downfall comment with your thoughts down
below or tweet me directly I da Voss and
follow the new rock stars on Twitter at
new rock stars or updates on our videos
and of course subscribe to new rockstars
for deep dives into everything marvel
breakdown from the infinity war trailers
predictions for where the MCU is headed
in phase 4 and a full MCU timeline of
all the events leading up to this point
and if you really like us and want to
help us grow you can contribute to this
channel on patreon a big thanks to all
of our donors especially Kristina
Armstrong thanks for watching guys bye